IDs or like homeownership everybody
should own a home right well we saw with
that tokus yeah when you lower the
requirements and suddenly we're all you
know it's blowing up and we're [ __ ]
but anyway what do I know what do I know
what do I know either but I I see your
points and I know I know what you're
saying I think that one thing that
disturbs the [ __ ] out of me is student
loans I mean you were one of the worst
ways to prepare a kid for the futures to
saddle them down with a quarter million
dollars worth of debt by the time they
graduate from college right now
absolutely and then they get a $50,000 a
year job and they're like what in the
end they're doing well with a $50,000 a
year job that's a great job to get out
of college and and you just look at the
debt that you have and you're like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah how am I gonna pay
this [ __ ] yeah no I know and and we have
sold the students a bill of goods yes
and and and you know some of it okay
some of it's on them right some of it
you know the older students are the ones
who are willing to take out this loan
and then suddenly they're using the
money for something else okay fine well
there's individual responsibility but no
I I agree with it the student loan debt
is a major issue we occasionally that
the Capitol Hill talks about it but not
really I told I told my daughter who's a
fantastic person this is you know the
biggest gift you're getting is getting
out of college without any any debt yeah
that's you know so you know dad's not
gonna buy you your own Wagoneer tuition
and that's that's that's it what's best
second that's a gigantic Head Start for
kids no I mean it sounds so [ __ ] up
but it's true to not be in debt is
gigantic look they're giving kids credit
cards and their frontal lobes aren't
even developed yet they're doing all
kinds of wacky they're like wow figure
it out like you ain't figuring out [ __ ]
you never figured out things up till now
and the idea that you're gonna get
magically smarter over the next six
months while you owe all this money is
crazy
right you kids do do you two oldest have
a phone yet for security we're scissor
what is this what do you got here Jam
student loan clock oh my god
what is I can't even figure out what
that is 1.6 trillion to go oh so what is
this website that people can I go to
this college debt calm I just typed in
student loan hold on
yes look at it wrapped up look at that
that is an insane amount of money thanks
pals Monroe second look I'm just kind of
guessing off what I'm seeing yeah oh
that's an insane amount of money so you
just made that number up you just don't
okay okay credit cards
auto loans is that credit cards not
Alone's for us all of us Americans or
student yes and then those it's all
credit card debt what I just looked at
two on another page that had a clock it
back it's this is the same number it's
it's not including the interest on the
federal loans that's that's crazy so so
you look at that you think okay no
wonder it's a it's a popular idea of
saying you gotta write down student
loans you've got to get free tuition
going on yeah do all these things and I
again you know can the country pay for
it I don't think so should we be talking
about it absolutely she'll be looking
for other alternatives and other options
yeah but you know I think it's it's you
know we're not even willing to address
the issue of Social Security and
Medicare and you know and and trying to
deal with entitlements as they currently
exist which we know you know are going
to bankrupt us at some point we know
that it's not it's not a mystery and we
can't deal with that so how are we gonna
deal with these other issues